Tyra: PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
WHILE JADE CONTINUED
TO SCRUTINIZE
GINA'S PERFORMANCE...
NOBODY'S GONNA WANT
A WEAK AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
HER UNEXPECTED MAKEOVER...
- OOH!
- RATTLED HER CONFIDENCE.
LOOK WHAT'S IN THE MAGAZINES
NOW--LONG HAIR, BABY.
AND WHEN
THE TEMPERATURE DROPPED...
NOW I WANT YOU TO FEEL
THIS ENVIRONMENT.
THE PRESSURE WENT UP...
YOU GOT A LITTLE VACANT
IN THE FACE.
AND WENDY FROZE UP...
A LITTLE MORE FEELING.
WHAT THE JUDGES SEE RIGHT NOW
IS A LOT OF POTENTIAL.
THEY HAVEN'T SEEN
THAT POTENTIAL PUT INTO A PHOTO.
AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
11 GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪ I WANT TO BE ON TOP ♪
♪ YOU WANT TO BE ON TOP ♪
♪ YOU WANT TO BE ON TOP ♪♪
♪♪♪
BEING THE LAST
FIVE GIRLS UP THERE,
- YOU'RE JUST LIKE--
- YEAH, IT'S HORRIBLE.
I TOLD JADE, I WAS LIKE,
"YOU'RE GONNA BE UP THERE
IN THE FINAL TWO."
SHE JUST KINDA LOOKED
AT ME LIKE, "BITCH."
WE KINDA FELT THAT JADE
WAS GONNA BE IN THE BOTTOM TWO
JUST BECAUSE SHE SEEMS
TO MAKE EXCUSES A LOT
WHEN SHE'S AT THE PANEL.
IT WAS ALSO, I THINK,
THE EYE MAKEUP, AS WELL.
IT WAS VERY--
YOU JUST CAN'T DO ALL THIS.
YOU CAN'T COMPLAIN.
THIS IS WHAT MODELING IS ABOUT.
THAT'S NOT A JOKE!
I WAS SWEATIN'.
YOU JUST BE, LIKE,
IN BLANK MODE UP THERE.
THAT'S A HUMBLING PLACE
TO BE.
GOTTA STEP UP THE GAME, ACE,
STEP UP THE GIZ-AME.
YOU HEARD.
THIS IS DISGUSTING.
EVERYONE,
WE'RE LIVING LIKE PIGS.
YOU CAN'T LET 'EM GET UNDER
YOUR SKIN, THOUGH.
I MEAN, I DON'T KNOW
WHAT YOU'VE BEEN THROUGH
- IN YOUR LIFE, BUT--
- NOT MUCH.
UNTIL YOU'VE BEEN THROUGH,
LIKE, SOME HARD KNOCKS,
IT TOUGHENS YOUR SKIN.
DANIELLE IS
A REALLY GOOD PERSON--
HELPING ME
AND TRYING TO COMFORT ME.
SHE'S SOMEONE WHO IS JUST--
JUST REALLY STRONG.
IT'S 'CAUSE, I MEAN,
I'VE BEEN THROUGH A LOT OF HELL
IN MY LIFE.
I GUESS I'VE ALWAYS BEEN NAIVE.
I'VE ALWAYS KINDA
TRUSTED PEOPLE, YOU KNOW?
DON'T CHANGE WHO YOU ARE,
BUT JUST, YOU KNOW, WATCH OUT.
I TRY TO ENCOURAGE GINA.
I DON'T MIND HER COMING TO ME
FOR ADVICE, BUT, YOU KNOW,
DANIELLE NEEDS HER SPACE, TOO.
- MAN, I GOT TO GO TO SLEEP.
- I'M GONNA FOLLOW YOU.
GINA, YOU MAKE ME NERVOUS.
I'M GONNA FOLLOW YOU
AFTER YOU'RE DONE.
YOU'RE WAITING TO TAKE A SHOWER?
- YEP.
- CAN I WATCH YOU?
GIRL, SHUT UP.
NO. YOU DON'T WATCH ME
TAKE SHOWERS.
I'M GONNA GO DO WHAT I DO.
- YOU'RE GONNA GO NOW?
- YEAH.
I'M FOLLOWING YOU.
I THINK SHE JUST GOT A LITTLE
BIT TOO COMFORTABLE WITH ME.
DANG.
I AIN'T ASKED YOU TO COME MOVE
IN MY BED WITH ME.
NO, I'LL STILL GIVE YOU ADVICE
EVERY NOW AND THEN, BUT DON'T,
LIKE, BE ALL UP IN MY ZONE.
♪♪♪
Y'ALL, WE GOT TYRA MAIL!
"CAUTION--TRAINS MAY COLLIDE.
WHO WILL HAVE THE LEG UP?"
TRAINS?
LIKE A CHOO-CHOO?
IMMEDIATELY, WE ALL KNEW
WE'D BE DOIN' THE RUNWAY.
I'VE GOTTA SHOW THEM, LIKE,
RIGHT OFF THE BAT
THAT I CAN DO IT.
♪♪♪
(cheers)
WHAT'S UP, GIRLS?
I'M LIKE, "YES--RUNWAY."
I WANT MISS J.
TO JUST CRITIQUE ME
AND TO MAKE ME BETTER.
OKAY, GIRLS.
WHAT I WANT YOU TO DO
IS I WANT YOU TO GET UP
ON THAT STAGE
AND JUST SHOW ME WHAT YOU HAVE.
YOU NEED TO BE ABLE TO SLINKY
INK DOWN THE RUNWAY.
IF YOU CAN'T SLINKY INK,
YOU MAY LOOK STINKY STINK.
I WANT YOU GIRLS
TO GO OVER THERE.
CHOOSE A PAIR OF SHOES.
FURONDA.
ATTITUDE STRONG,
STRONG, STRONG.
IS YOUR LEFT ARM
ATTACHED TO YOUR BODY?
OKAY.
MOLLIE SUE.
SCANDALOUS.
I WANT FABULOUS.
YOU TAKE
SHORT LITTLE STOMPY STEPS
THAT MAKE YOU WALK HEAVY.
LESLIE.
(laughs)
OOH, CHILD.
I NEED YOU TO SHAPE YOUR BODY
NOT LIKE THIS,
LIKE THIS.
NNENNA, BUST IT OUT.
FASTER.
I NEED TO SEE A LITTLE BIT
OF THAT AFRICAN FIRE.
BROOKE.
I NEED A STRUT.
SARA, DON'T MARCH, WALK.
I WAS A LITTLE NERVOUS,
AND, LIKE, MY FEET
WERE A LITTLE SWEATY,
SO THAT WAS NOT THE BEST WAY
TO START IT OUT.
SARA--SHE IS SO TALL.
SHE LOOKED LIKE SHE WAS,
LIKE, 6'5'' WITH THOSE HEELS.
SHE LOOKED LIKE SHE WAS
STRESSIN' OUT A LITTLE BIT.
JOANIE.
STRONGER.
THE ONE THING I DON'T FIND
WITH YOU, JOANIE,
IS YOU DON'T HAVE ANY SENSE
OF RHYTHM WITH THE MUSIC.
GINA.
STRONGER.
YOU'RE ALMOST KINDA LIKE
YOU WANNA SKIP OR BOUNCE.
I THINK GINA'S CONFIDENCE
IS 45% THERE,
WHICH IS NOT
A VERY LARGE PERCENT
OUT OF 100%.
DANIELLE.
A LITTLE MORE FIRE
OR YOU'LL BURN THE HOUSE DOWN.
JADE.
I FEEL LIKE YOU'RE HOLDIN' BACK.
I NEED TO SEE FIRE.
KARI.
I'VE NEVER DONE RUNWAY,
AND BEING CRITIQUED BY MISS J.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IS SCARY.
I WANT ENERGY.
I WANT YOU TO BE QUITE STRONG
AND INCREDIBLE, INTENSE.
STRONGER AND FASTER.
(record scratches)
TIPPY TUMBLES.
HEY.
KARI, BECAUSE YOU STUMBLED,
YOUR FACE WENT COMPLETELY...
(laughs)
SHE DOESN'T KNOW HOW TO REALLY
GIVE YOU THE ATTITUDE
THAT IS NEEDED.
I HAVE SOME DRESSES BACK HERE.
YOU'RE ACTUALLY GONNA
PUT THESE DRESSES ON,
AND YOU'RE GONNA WALK FOR ME.
YOU GIRLS, READY?
LET'S GO, KARI.
STRONG.
KARI, THAT WAS SCARY.
HONESTLY,
I THINK KARI JUST WANTED
TO RUN OFF THE RUNWAY
WHEN SHE TRIPPED.
LIKE, EVERY TIME
SHE WENT UP THERE,
SHE TRIPPED.
I'M, YOU KNOW, VERY GRACEFUL,
I GUESS.
GIRL, YOU'RE TOO SAFE.
I THINK WITH THE CRITICISM
THAT THE JUDGES
HAVE GIVEN JADE RECENTLY,
I THINK IT KINDA
BROKE HER SPIRIT A BIT.
YOU TRYIN' TO HOLD BACK.
I WAS, LIKE, IN A SHELL.
I NEEDED TO OPEN UP AGAIN.
WORK THE BOTTOM OF THE DRESS.
STRONGER, MOLLIE.
COMPETITION-WISE,
I HAVEN'T DONE ANYTHING
THAT'S, LIKE, WOWED.
I NEED A STRUT.
MOLLIE SUE--
SHE NEEDS TO CONNECT
WITH THE AUDIENCE
IN A MUCH MORE INTENSE,
MORE POWERFUL WAY.
LEAN BACK.
DROP THAT DRESS.
LEAVE IT ALONE.
STRONGER. STRONGER.
FASTER. STRONGER.
SEXY.
CONTROL YOUR SHOULDERS.
YOU ALMOST LOOK CRAZY.
GINA, I NEED YOU
TO WALK A LOT FASTER THAN THAT.
I HAVE THIS TENDENCY TO JUST
KIND OF GET NERVOUS AND SHY,
AND I TEND TO LOSE FOCUS.
SHE WAS VERY, VERY SAFE
IN HER LET-'EM-EAT-CAKE DRESS.
I WANTED HER TO SERVE US
ALL A PIECE, BUT SHE DIDN'T.
I'M LIKE, "OKAY, DANIELLE.
"YOU NEED TO WALK THIS WALK
LIKE THIS IS
YOUR FIRST AND LAST TIME
TO EVER DO IT AGAIN."
I FEEL MYSELF FALLING OVER
AND TUMBLIN',
NOT A STUTTER STEP, BUT LIKE,
ALMOST A BASH-YOUR-CHIN STEP.
IN MY HEAD, I'M LIKE,
PRETTY MUCH JUST THIS MESSED
THIS ALL THE WAY UP.
DANIELLE--
I THOUGHT SHE WAS SERIOUSLY
GONNA FALL OFF THE RUNWAY.
DON'T LET IT
BREAK THE SPIRIT.
WE HAVE SOME WORK TO DO.
YOU ALL WERE WALKING
VERY, VERY SAFE.
THE LESSON NEVER STOPS HERE,
BECAUSE YOU WILL BE JUDGED
ON THIS,
AND IT MAY HAPPEN
SOONER THAN YOU THINK.
THE PRESSURE'S, LIKE,
REALLY, REALLY ON.
I'M LIKE, "OKAY, DAN,
THIS CAN EITHER MAKE YOU
"OR IT CAN BREAK YOU,
AND YOU DON'T WANT IT
TO BREAK YOU."
♪♪♪
EVERYBODY HAS BAD DAYS,
LIKE, EVERYBODY HERE HAS LOWS.
THIS WAS DEFINITELY
A REALITY CHECK FOR ME,
LIKE, EVERYBODY'S ENTITLED
TO HAVIN' A BAD DAY,
BUT YOU KNOW, HERE, YOU'RE NOT
SUPPOSED TO HAVE BAD DAYS.
MY MOM IS LIKE MY BATTERY.
I'D LIKE TO MEET YOUR MOM.
SHE SOUNDS REALLY COOL.
OH, SHE IS WONDERFUL
'CAUSE SHE HAS ARTHRITIS,
SO SHE'S BEEN SICK
FOR, LIKE, ALL MY LIFE.
JUST TO SEE HER, LIKE,
GO THROUGH EVERYDAY LIFE
AND NOT COMPLAIN,
IT'S LIKE, "DANG,"
LIKE, "YOU'RE A STRONG WOMAN."
(dial tone)
HELLO?
I LOVE BEING HERE,
BUT I MISS THE SUPPORT
I GET AT HOME, AND YOU KNOW,
THE LOVE FROM ALL THE FAMILY.
HOW WAS YOUR DAY?
- GOOD.
- IS EVERYTHING OKAY?
I MISS HOME.
I KNOW YOU DO, HONEY.
I KNOW YOU DO.
man: IT'S A GOOD
GROWING-UP EXPERIENCE,
IT REALLY IS.
mother: SO HOW COME
I'M GOING THROUGH IT, TOO?
I'M OLD.
THE NEWNESS OF BEING HERE
IS KINDA FADING AWAY,
SO KINDA REALITY'S SITTING IN,
BUT I NEED TO MAINLY FOCUS
ON GOIN' FURTHER AND FURTHER.
TYRA MAIL!
I DON'T THINK
I CAN PRONOUNCE THIS.
IT SAYS, "TWO WORDS--
GROMPHADORHINA PORTENTOSA."
IS IT, LIKE, ONE OF THOSE WORDS
THAT SOUNDS LIKE SOMETHING ELSE?
GROMPHADORHINA.
PORTENTOSA.
(screeches)
WE ALL JUMPIN' DOWN,
THINKIN' WE'RE GOIN' TO SPAIN,
BUT THEN WE STOP AND WE'RE LIKE,
"WE'RE NOT GOIN' TO SPAIN."
OKAY. WHAT'S THE WORD?
I GOT IT.
JADE HAS A SPELL CHECKER,
AND WE'RE PUTTING
- THE WORDS IN...
- "I-N-A."
IT BASICALLY MEANS, LIKE,
UM--WHAT DOES IT MEAN?
GRAVY TRAINS!
- GRAVY TRAINS.
- THE TRAINS OF GOWNS.
- GRANDE.
- DRESSES.
- PORTENTOSA.
- PORTLY.
- FAT HATS?
THAT'S WHAT THAT MEANS?
♪♪♪
(alarm beeps)
VANILLA ALMOND AND REGULAR.
YOU GUYS,
WE'RE LEAVING NOW.
WELCOME, WELCOME, WELCOME.
TODAY, YOU'RE HERE
AT SMASHBOX STUDIOS
WHERE THEY HOST
L.A.'s FASHION WEEK,
AND TODAY,
YOU'RE GOING TO MEET A DESIGNER
KNOWN AS JARED GOLD
FROM THE JARED GOLD COLLECTION.
♪♪♪
THIS IS JARED GOLD.
TODAY,
YOU'RE GOING TO BE WALKING
IN MY SPRING COLLECTION,
WHICH IS CALLED GLINKA.
IT'S THIS KINDA PSYCHEDELIC
BABUSHKA ACID WITCH--
VERY, VERY DARK.
YOU WILL BE JUDGED BY ME
AND MY TEAM
OF FASHION ADVISORS.
YOU'VE GOT, LIKE, AN HOUR
TO GET INTO HAIR AND MAKEUP,
SO MAKE IT HAPPEN.
♪♪♪
YES, SOME ELMER'S GLUE,
SOME SILLY PUTTY.
OUR MAKEUP IS BLACK EYES,
ROSY CHEEKS--
ALMOST LIKE A HOOKER
FROM BACK IN, YOU KNOW,
THE OLD HOOKER TIMES, I GUESS.
MY LOOK IS VERY ECCENTRIC
AND VERY STRONG, AND SO...
HEY, YOU KNOW WHAT?
SO IS MINE.
I HAVE TO SHINE.
I HAVEN'T BEEN DOIN' WELL,
SO THIS IS MY CHANCE.
THIS COLLECTION
IS VERY ORNATE,
BUT I FEEL WE MIGHT STILL
BE MISSING A LITTLE SOMETHING
FROM IT,
MAYBE AN ACCESSORY OR SOMETHING.
MR. JARED HAS THIS GOBLET,
AND I'M LIKE, "OKAY.
"WE'RE GONNA GET TO HOLD
THE GOBLET DOWN THE RUNWAY
"JUST LIKE SOME LITTLE
MINI PIMPS, YOU KNOW,
FEMALE PIMPS."
I'M LIKE, "THAT'S COOL."
DESIGNERS
DO ALL SORTS OF CRAZY THINGS
TO GET INTO THE PRESS,
SO YOU, AS MODELS,
HAVE TO BE READY FOR ANYTHING.
THESE ARE GIANT MADAGASCAR
HISSING COCKROACHES.
(gasps)
WE HAVE ACTUALLY
USED THESE ROACHES
IN RUNWAY SHOWS BEFORE.
OH, DON'T DO THIS.
EVERYBODY IS GOING
TO HAVE TO WEAR ONE OF THESE.
OH!
THAT'S AWESOME.
THEY HAVE A LEASH ON THEM.
THEY WON'T GET AWAY.
SO WHAT THIS CHALLENGE
IS REALLY ABOUT
IS TO SEE HOW YOU HANDLE
THE OUTRAGEOUS THINGS
THAT THE FASHION WORLD
CAN THROW OUT AT YOU.
I SEE THESE LITTLE THINGS,
LIKE, MOVING,
AND I SEE THE LEGS MOVING,
AND I'M LIKE, "OH, MY GOODNESS."
I JUST START TO, LIKE, PUKE
IN MY MOUTH A LITTLE BIT.
I'M LIKE, "OH."
LET'S GET EVERYBODY LINED UP.
THIS MAY BE YOUR ONE CHANCE
TO JUST REALLY LET IT FLY,
SO LET'S SEE IT.
SO I MESSED UP YESTERDAY.
WELL, YOU KNOW,
I GOTTA KEEP GOIN'.
AND I'LL BE ABLE
TO REDEEM MYSELF
AND LET EVERYBODY KNOW
THAT I KNOW HOW TO WALK.
READY AND GO.
DANIELLE LOOKS GREAT.
OH, HE'S GOING CRAZY.
FURONDA'S GOT HER ARM OUT,
AND IT'S ALL WEIRD.
HIT IT.
YOU'RE TOO FAST, BROOKE.
SLOW IT DOWN.
BUG FOR HER, QUICK.
SHE NEEDS A BUG RIGHT HERE.
COME ON, LET GO.
IT'S ALL RIGHT.
THERE'S NO INTENSITY.
LET'S GO. LET'S GO.
STEP IT UP.
YOU GUYS ARE SO AWESOME.
EVERYONE'S MAINTAINING
PRETTY GOOD COMPOSURE.
KISS IT, COME ON.
KISS IT. KISS IT.
NO, IT'S OKAY.
I HATE COCKROACHES
WITH A PASSION.
I HATE THEM.
I REALLY JUST HATE THEM.
JADE SEES THAT AS AN OPPORTUNITY
WHERE SHE CAN JUST KIND OF
INTIMIDATE ME.
STAND UP STRAIGHT.
WALK UPRIGHT.
TOO CLUNKY, MOLLIE.
HER ROACH IS ON HER BACK.
OKAY, READY?
I WAS A LITTLE NERVOUS
BECAUSE THIS WHOLE EXPERIENCE
IS HAVING THINGS
JUST THROWN AT YOU.
GO.
THIS GIRL NEEDS TO WALK
A LITTLE FASTER.
OKAY, GO.
HE'S PISSED.
(laughing)
DID YOU SEE THAT?
SHE TOOK IT IN HER HAND.
OH, SHE KISSED IT.
THEY LOVED IT.
DUDE, THEY LOVED IT.
I JUST GAVE HIM A LITTLE PECK,
AND I WAS LIKE, "HELL, YES."
JADE, YOU'RE AWESOME.
PLEASE DON'T GRAB MY HAND.
OKAY, HON, GET READY.
(squeals)
GET HIM ON FRONT.
GET HIM ON THE FRONT.
(moans)
I'M FREAKED OUT.
I CAN'T HANDLE IT,
AND I'M REALLY THINKING,
MAYBE I JUST SHOULDN'T DO THIS.
GO FOR IT, GIRL.
- (moans)
- OKAY, READY?
PRINCESS,
YOU GOTTA GET IT TOGETHER.
(screeches)
YOU'RE HOLDING UP THE SHOW.
GET IT TOGETHER.
- GO!
- AH!
OKAY, READY?
GINA, I NEED YOU
OUT THERE RIGHT NOW.
YOU GOTTA GET IT TOGETHER.
WHEN THE COCKROACH IS ON ME,
I CAN'T MOVE.
I AM LITERALLY PARALYZED.
GET IT TOGETHER.
GO!
AH!
OUT.
♪♪♪
(laughs)
GET IT OFF ME, PLEASE!
ALL RIGHT, JOANIE.
THAT'S IT.
GINA WAS FREAKIN' OUT.
WHAT ARE YOU DOIN'?
THIS IS COMPETITION.
I WOULD HAVE HAD
FOUR OF THEM THINGS ON ME.
THAT WAS ON MY NECK, DUDE.
MIND OVER MATTER.
IT WAS HORRIBLE, OH, GOD.
THE FREAK-OUT AWARD
GOES TO GINA.
♪♪♪
LADIES, MY STYLE PANEL AND I
HAVE GONE THROUGH
YOUR PERFORMANCE
AND THE VIDEO,
AND WE HAVE SOME CRITIQUES.
DANIELLE SASHAYS LIKE A GODDESS.
MOLLIE SUE, YOU WALK LIKE
YOU'RE IN THE GESTAPO.
LESLIE LEADS WITH THE NOSE.
KARI, YOU NEED TO REALLY THINK
A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT PROJECTING THE VIBE.
JADE, GREAT CONFIDENCE,
VERY SEDUCTIVE.
YOU KISSED THE ROACH.
I MEAN, HI.
GINA, I HAD TO PHYSICALLY
PUSH YOU ONTO THE RUNWAY.
YOU LOST IT, AND YOU NEVER
REGAINED YOUR COMPOSURE.
JOANIE,
YOU HAD REALLY GOOD POSES.
FURONDA, IT LOOKED LIKE YOU WERE
WALKING AN INVISIBLE DOG.
BROOKE, YOU NEED TO SLOW DOWN.
NNENNA, I THINK YOU WERE
A LITTLE TOO SWISHY.
SARA, YOU ARE SO TALL,
AND YOU JUST NEED TO OWN IT.
SO WE HAVE DECIDED
THAT FOR THIS CHALLENGE
THAT JADE IS THE WINNER
FOR THIS ROUND.
WHOO-HOO!
THANK YOU, GUYS.
THAT'S RIGHT!
I WAS LIKE, "HELL, YES."
I REDEEMED MYSELF.
YOU CAN PICK FOUR FRIENDS.
OF COURSE, NNENNA.
UM, DANIELLE, MOLLIE
AND LESLIE.
JADE AND HER PARTY
WILL BE GETTING
THE TOTAL V.I.P. TREATMENT
AT THE SHERI BODELL RUNWAY SHOW
HERE AT FASHION WEEK
IMMEDIATELY AFTER THIS.
BEAUTIFUL.
IT'S SO EXCITING.
THE V.I.P. TREATMENT--
I COULDN'T WAIT FOR THAT.
♪♪♪
HI.
WELCOME TO MERCEDES-BENZ
FASHION WEEK
AT SMASHBOX STUDIOS.
TODAY, YOU'RE THE V.I.P.s.
ALL RIGHT, COME ON,
LET'S GO IN.
WE THE V.I.P.
♪♪♪
THE FASHION SHOW
WAS AWESOME, MAN.
I WANNA WALK IN THAT SHOW.
I WANNA WALK IN FRONT OF PEOPLE.
I'M 26 YEARS OLD,
AND I STILL NEVER
FULFILLED MY DREAM,
AND I JUST WANT PEOPLE
TO SEE MY TALENT.
BUT YOU'RE HAVIN'
A GOOD TIME, THOUGH, RIGHT?
YEAH.
I'M HAVIN' A GREAT TIME.
TODAY WAS ACTUALLY
A REALLY GOOD DAY FOR ME, SO...
THAT'S GOOD.
KINDA REDEEMED MYSELF TODAY.
YOU KNOW, THE CONSTRUCTIVE
CRITICISM IS JUST LIKE...
WHOO.
THE THING THAT, YOU KNOW, KINDA
IRRITATES ME IS THEY KINDA GET--
MY CONFIDENCE THEY'RE GETTING
CONFUSED WITH ARROGANCE.
SOMETIMES SOME PEOPLE
PERCEIVE THAT, YOU KNOW.
- I HATE THAT.
- TO ME, YOU'VE ALREADY WON.
I SO APPRECIATE...
- HEY.
- EVERYTHING YOU SAY.
I LOVE YOU.
I LOVE YOU, TOO.
- BYE-BYE.
- BYE.
♪♪♪
I HAVE CONFIDENCE.
I REALLY DO.
I KNOW THAT I HAVE POTENTIAL,
BUT, LIKE,
IT'S HARD TO BRING IT OUT.
WE'RE OUR OWN WORST CRITIC,
RIGHT, EVERYBODY.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYIN'?
WE'RE HARD ON OURSELF.
I'VE HARD A HARD-KNOCK LIFE,
BUT, YOU KNOW,
I GOTTA PUT A SMILE ON MY FACE.
THAT'S WHAT YOU DO
WHEN YOU A MODEL.
YOU CAN'T COMPLAIN.
YOU GOTTA KEEP GOIN' WITH IT.
I DON'T KNOW, I'M ALWAYS SO USED
TO EXPECTING THE WORST,
AND IT'S SO HARD TO EXPECT
THE WORST AND TRY YOUR BEST,
YOU KNOW?
I DEFINITELY NEED TO DEVELOP
TOUGHER SKIN FOR MYSELF.
- TYRA MAIL!
TYRA MAIL!
(laughs)
"ONCE UPON A TIME,
THERE WAS A TOP MODEL,
AND SHE LIVED
HAPPILY EVER AFTER."
(cheers)
WE'RE GONNA BE PRETTY.
♪♪♪
SO WHAT DID YOU GIRLS LEARN
ABOUT THIS WEEK?
all: TO WALK.
TO WALK LIKE A RUNWAY MODEL.
SOMETIME IN YOUR CAREER
AS A MODEL,
YOU MIGHT JUST ACCIDENTALLY
TRIP AND FALL ON A RUNWAY.
AND YOU KNOW,
ALL THE CAMERAS ARE GONNA GO...
(imitates clicking sounds)
TAKE PICTURES.
YOU GOTTA LOOK GRACEFUL
ACTUALLY FALLING DOWN
AND LOOKIN' PRETTY.
SO, TODAY, WE'RE ACTUALLY
GONNA DO A PHOTO SHOOT
WITH YOU GIRLS KIND OF FALLING.
NOW I HAD TO BRING ONE
OF MY FAVORITE PHOTOGRAPHERS.
TRACY IS GONNA
SHOOT YOU GIRLS TODAY.
- HOW YA DOIN'?
- WE DO THE BLONDE THING.
♪♪♪
BACK THERE, YOU NEED
TO COORDINATE IT UP HERE.
SO AS YOU'RE DOIN' THE FALL,
YOU GOTTA THINK OF THE FACE.
NOW TYRA--
SHE WANTED TO PUT A LITTLE TWIST
ON THE SHOOT TODAY.
WE THOUGHT WE'D MAKE YOU GIRLS
MODERN-DAY FAIRY TALES.
(laughs)
FURONDA,
WE'RE GONNA MAKE YOU RAPUNZEL.
LESLIE, WE'RE GONNA MAKE YOU
A SEXY BIG BAD WOLF.
JADE, YOU ARE ACTUALLY GOING TO
BE LITTLE RED RIDING HOOD.
MOLLIE SUE, YOU'RE GONNA BE
LITTLE BOY BLUE.
DANIELLE, WE'RE GONNA HAVE
THE FIRST BLACK SNOW WHITE.
WHAT? YEAH.
GINA, YOU'RE GONNA BE
SLEEPING BEAUTY.
BROOKE, HAVE YOU EVER HEARD
OF "THE EMPEROR'S NEW CLOTHES"?
YEAH.
BUT WE'RE GONNA PLAY IT UP,
MAKE IT KINDA CUTE.
KARI, WITH THAT HAIR,
WE GOTTA MAKE YOU GOLDILOCKS.
NNENNA, HAVE YOU HEARD
OF "THE PRINCESS AND THE FROG"?
- NO.
- YOU'RE BASICALLY THE PRINCESS.
JOANIE--CINDERELLA.
AND SARA--GRETEL
OF "HANSEL AND GRETEL."
TRACY'S GONNA ACTUALLY
SHOW YOU THE MOVEMENT.
AND YOU'LL GO ONE, TWO.
SO IT'S GONNA BE FUN.
WE'RE NOT JUST DOING
A REGULAR FASHION SHOOT.
LET'S GET YOU GUYS BACK
INTO HAIR AND MAKEUP.
- WHO ARE YOU?
- RAPUNZEL.
♪♪♪
I WANNA IMPRESS JAY
BECAUSE THE PAST SHOOTS,
HE REALLY HASN'T SEEN
WHAT I REALLY CAN POSSESS,
SO I WANTED TO ROCK
THIS PHOTO SHOOT.
READY, SWEETIE?
SORRY.
ONE.
THAT LOOKED PRETTY.
EXCELLENT.
GREAT.
OOH, I LIKE THAT ONE.
THE FIRST GIRL THAT WAS UP
WAS JADE.
SHE DID REALLY GREAT,
AND SHE PUT THE BAR
WAY UP THERE,
AND I GOT KIND OF SCARED.
THAT WAS REALLY GOOD, JADE.
GORGEOUS, HONEY.
CINDERELLA--
IT'S ALL ABOUT HER DRESS.
ONE, TWO.
I DIDN'T EXPECT IT
TO BE AS PHYSICALLY CHALLENGING
AS IT WAS,
BUT IT'S DEFINITELY--
IT TAKES A LOT
OF STRENGTH AND CONTROL.
TWO.
GORGEOUS.
YOU'RE RAPUNZEL.
WHY DID YOU GROW THIS HAIR?
TO GET A MAN.
♪♪♪
RIGHT NOW, YOU LOOK LIKE
YOU'RE KINDA CLUNKIN' ON A MAT.
REALLY?
WHAT DOES MY FACE LOOK LIKE?
LIKE YOU'RE CLUNKIN'
ON A MAT.
(choking sound)
I'M TRYIN' TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO LOOK SEXY
AND FALL AND EVERYTHING.
IT'S GONNA BE QUITE A FALL.
I KNOW.
I HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO.
I HAVE A LONG WAY TO FALL.
- TIMBER!
- TIMBER.
♪♪♪
WHEN YOU FALL,
YOU'RE TRYING TO KEEP YOUR HEAD
STRAIGHT UP AND DOWN.
YEAH.
SARA, YOUR EXPRESSION--
IT LOOKS A LITTLE
BLOW-UP-DOLLISH.
IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE GRETEL,
NOT BLOW-UP GRETEL.
VERY PRETTY.
MY WALK WAS HORRIBLE,
BUT THE PHOTOGRAPH IS,
AT THE END OF THE DAY,
THE MOST IMPORTANT ASPECT
IN THIS.
♪♪♪
A LITTLE BIT MORE EXPRESSION.
THAT LAST ONE
WAS A LITTLE TOO HAPPY.
IT WAS A LITTLE TOO, AH!
I WAS A LITTLE NERVOUS--
WHERE TO PUT MY HEAD,
MY FACIAL EXPRESSION,
WHERE MY ARMS
WERE SUPPOSED TO BE.
THIS IS THE LAST FRAME.
IT'S DEFINITELY IMPORTANT
TO GET A GOOD PHOTOGRAPH TODAY.
SO YOU READY TO GIVE ME
FACIAL EXPRESSIONS TODAY?
GREAT PLENTY.
ONE, TWO--
LOOK AT ME--THREE.
♪♪♪
IN MY PHOTO SHOOTS,
I THINK I JUST NEED
TO KEEP MY HEAD ON STRAIGHT
AND JUST BLOW EVERYONE AWAY
AND SHOW THEM MY PERSONALITY.
THREE.
YOU KNOW WHAT, IF I WAS
HONESTLY AS PRETTY AS YOU,
MAYBE I WOULDN'T HAVE
TRIED SO HARD, EITHER, GIRL.
IT LOOKED LIKE
I DIDN'T TRY HARD?
I THINK WHEN YOU'RE TRYING,
YOU'RE...
(imitates sucking sound)
HOLDING IT IN.
IF I ASKED YOU JUST TO YELL,
SCREAM ON THE TOP
OF YOUR LUNGS--GO AHEAD.
DO IT.
(screams)
THAT IS NOT SCREAMING
ON THE TOP OF YOUR LUNGS.
YEAH, IT IS.
I NEED YOU
TO JUST JUMP ALL THE WAY OUT.
(screams)
YOU NEED
TO COME OUTTA YOUR SHELL.
WITH MOLLIE SUE,
I MIGHT HAVE ALMOST
BROKE HER DOWN,
BUT I STILL GOT NOTHING.
I KNOW I'M TRYING,
I JUST--I'M COMING UP SHORT.
THEY MIGHT BE LIKE,
"WELL, THIS WERE HER, YOU KNOW,
"THIRD PHOTO SHOOT.
SHE SHOULD HAVE IT BY NOW."
♪♪♪
GORGEOUS.
ONE, TWO.
- GORGEOUS.
- GOOD JOB, LESLIE.
TWO.
EXCELLENT.
IT'S LIKE...
(laughs)
GREAT.
GOOD JOB.
♪♪♪
YOU'RE ROLLING YOUR EYES BACK
INTO YOUR HEAD,
AND YOU'RE JUST
STIFF AS A BOARD.
CAN YOU DO THIS?
- YES.
- OKAY.
I NEED TO SEE SOME MOVEMENT
'CAUSE RIGHT NOW,
I'M SEEIN' THIS...
MUCH BETTER!
HAVE FUN WITH THIS ONE.
GIGGLE.
LET'S SEE SOME TEETH.
- GOOD JOB.
- YUP.
MAN, WHEN I PUT THE OUTFIT ON
AND GOT INTO HAIR AND MAKEUP,
THAT'S WHEN I GOT
ACTUALLY INTO CHARACTER.
TWO.
GORGEOUS.
I FELT LIKE SNOW WHITE--
OR, SORRY, SNOW BLACK.
♪♪♪
READY?
THINK SLOW MOTION.
I FEEL EVERYTHING
FROM THAT FALLIN'.
WHEW.
AS LONG AS I GOT A GOOD SHOT,
YOU KNOW,
I CAN DEAL WITH THE PAIN.
READY?
THREE.
BEAUTIFUL.
DANIELLE WAS
ONE OF MY FAVORITES TODAY.
SHE HAD GREAT BODY ANGLES,
AND SHE LOOKED
SEXY AND CONFIDENT.
- GORGEOUS.
- NICE JOB.
THAT WAS AMAZING.
HER FACIAL EXPRESSIONS
ARE GREAT.
I SIT THERE WITH TYRA AND GO,
"I DID NOT
SEE THIS GIRL COMIN'."
- WOW.
- YOU BLINDSIDED ME.
THAT'S A GOOD THING, THOUGH.
I'M GONNA DO WELL.
I'M KIND OF SCARED.
JAY TOLD ME WHEN I WALK
INTO THE PHOTO SHOOT,
I SHOULD JUST BE
WORKIN' IT AND ROCKIN' IT
FROM THE BEGINNING TO THE END.
ONE, TWO.
ONE, TWO, THREE.
CHIN NEEDS TO COME DOWN
A LITTLE BIT.
WHAT'S SHOWING ON THE FRAME
IS YOUR FACE
ANTICIPATING HITTING THE MAT.
THREE.
OKAY, THAT ONE, YOU JUST FELL.
SLOW, SLOW, SLOW.
SHE WAS LIKE...
UNH-UNH, UNH-UNH.
YOU'RE THINKIN' AGAIN.
I LOOKED OVER AT JADE,
AND JADE IS, LIKE,
MAKING SOUR FACES,
AND IT'S REALLY--
IT'S ANNOYING ME.
♪♪♪
YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENED?
YOU GOT TECHNICAL AGAIN.
YOU WERE JUST VACANT.
I KNOW I CAN DO GOOD.
I KNOW I CAN.
I'M JUST LETTING THE LITTLE
PETTY THINGS GET TO ME.
IT WAS A LONG DAY.
YOU GUYS CAN GO HOME.
♪♪♪
"TOMORROW, YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
"ONLY TEN WILL CONTINUE ON
IN THE HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
- DANG.
- TYRA.
SOMEBODY GOIN' HOME TOMORROW.
I CRIED ABOUT IT
FOR ABOUT SIX HOURS.
THERE'S A CHANCE I MIGHT GO HOME
BECAUSE THEY'RE JUST LIKE,
"WELL, YOU KNOW WHAT,
SHE'S JUST NOT TRYING ENOUGH."
I FEEL THAT I DID VERY WELL
IN OUR PHOTO SHOOT.
AT JUDGING, THEY ALWAYS SAY
THAT THEY'RE
PLEASANTLY SURPRISED
WITH HOW I DID, SO I HOPE
TO KEEP SURPRISING THEM.
I REALLY THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE
WANT GINA TO GO HOME.
I WOULDN'T EVEN MIND
SEEING GINA GO HOME.
THE SECOND WE HAVE
TO DO SOMETHING,
SHE IS THE FIRST ONE
TO FREAK OUT.
AH!
I HAVEN'T BEEN PERFORMING SO
WELL IN ANY OF THESE CHALLENGES,
SO I'M JUST REALLY HERE
BY, LIKE, THE SKIN OF MY TEETH.
♪♪♪
WELCOME, LADIES.
HI.
IT'S TIME TO MAKE
OUR THIRD CUT,
WHICH WILL BRING US
ONE STEP CLOSER
TOWARDS DETERMINING
WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
AND YOU KNOW OF OUR PRIZES.
FIRST IS A MODELING CONTRACT
WITH THE TOP INTERNATIONAL
MODELING MANAGEMENT COMPANY--
FORD MODELS--
A SPREAD IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE
THAT WILL BE SHOT
BY WORLD RENOWNED PHOTOGRAPHER
GILLES BENSIMON,
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
AND OF COURSE, YOU HAVE COME
TO KINDA KNOW OUR JUDGES.
THE FIRST IS THE NOTED
FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER
NIGEL BARKER,
OUR FABULOUS DIVA RUNWAY COACH
MISS J. ALEXANDER,
AND LEGENDARY FASHION ICON
TWIGGY.
AND, OF COURSE,
OUR GUEST JUDGE JARED GOLD.
JARED IS AN AMAZING
AMERICAN AVANT-GARDE DESIGNER.
THIS WEEK, YOU LEARNED ABOUT
HOW TO WALK THE RUNWAY
BY THE FABULOUS MISS J.
TODAY, YOU'RE GONNA BE PUT
TO THE ULTIMATE TEST.
VIVIENNE WESTWOOD IS KNOWN
FOR HAVING FASHION SHOWS THAT
ARE KIND OF VICTORIAN INSPIRED.
AND A LOT OF THE TIME,
SHE HAS MODELS WEAR SHOES
THAT ARE VERY UNCOMFORTABLE
AND VERY HIGH.
THEY'RE SO UNCOMFORTABLE THAT
ONE OF THE MOST FAMOUS MODELS
IN THE ENTIRE WORLD WORE THEM
AND FELL TO HER BOOTY
ON THE RUNWAY
IN THESE SHOES.
A NEW MODEL
CANNOT FALL OR STUMBLE
IN SHOES LIKE THESE.
CLOSE YOUR MOUTH, GINA,
YOU'RE CATCHIN' FLIES.
SO EVERYBODY GO TO THE BACK,
AND WE'RE GONNA GET THOSE SHOES
ON YOU.
KARI.
♪♪♪
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
TAKE YOUR TIME.
SLOW DOWN.
♪♪♪
OOH!
WHEW.
UH, WAIT, WAIT.
JUST WAIT.
GATHER YOURSELF
BEFORE YOU STEP UP THOSE STAIRS.
MAKE SURE YOUR ANKLES
ARE STRAIGHT.
OKAY, NOW YOU CAN EXIT.
THERE YOU GO.
OOH.
♪♪♪
GOODNESS.
UP NEXT IS SARA.
♪♪♪
BROOKE.
JADE.
♪♪♪
WEEBLES WOBBLE
BUT THEY DON'T FALL DOWN.
UP NEXT IS LESLIE.
TAKE YOUR TIME.
UP NEXT IS NNENNA.
♪♪♪
AH!
TAKE YOUR TIME, NNENNA.
TAKE YOUR TIME.
NEXT IS GINA.
♪♪♪
MISS MOLLIE SUE.
WHOO.
FURONDA.
♪♪♪
JOANIE.
- ALL RIGHT.
- YEAH.
DANIELLE.
♪♪♪
ARE YOU OKAY?
- YOU OKAY?
- I'M OKAY.
- OKAY.
SLOW DOWN
♪♪♪
OW. OW. OW. OW.
WHEW.
THIS IS THE MOST
NERVE-RACKING JUDGING TEST
WE HAVE EVER DONE.
OH.
I WAS HOLDING MY BREATH
THE ENTIRE TIME.
JUST KEEP HER--
KEEP HER FOOT ELEVATED.
BOTH MY FEET
WERE JUST THROBBING.
THEY WERE PULSATING.
OKAY, DOCTOR'S GONNA BE HERE.
I WAS JUST LIKE,
"I DON'T KNOW IF I'M GONNA
BE ABLE TO DO THIS."
♪♪♪
I TRIED TO PUT MY OWN
LITTLE RUNWAY WALK INTO IT,
AND IT WAS BAD.
CAREFUL.
WELCOME BACK, LADIES.
THAT WAS A VERY DIFFICULT TEST,
SO DIFFICULT
THAT SOMEBODY DID WHAT?
SPRAINED MY BABY TOE.
IT HURTS, BUT YOU KNOW,
THE BEST FALL DOWN SOMETIMES,
AS LONG AS YOU GET BACK UP.
ALL RIGHTY, WELL, NOW IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR CRITIQUE.
FIRST IS JADE.
SO YOU HAD TO PUT ON
THE VIVIAN WESTWOOD-INSPIRED
KILLER SHOES.
I THOUGHT
YOU HELD IT TOGETHER VERY WELL.
EVEN WHEN YOU STUMBLED,
YOU GOT IT BACK.
YAY.
AND YOU WON THE CHALLENGE
THIS WEEK.
WELL DONE, YOU.
AND SHE KISSED THE ROACH.
- SHE KISSED THE ROACH?
- IT WAS JUST A LITTLE PECK.
ALL RIGHT, JADE,
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU HAD TO BE
A FAIRY TALE FALLING.
AND, JADE, HERE IS
YOUR BEST SHOT.
YOU WERE LITTLE RED RIDING HOOD.
JADE, WHAT I REALLY LIKE
ABOUT THIS PHOTOGRAPH OF YOU
IS IT SHOWS THAT YOU'RE
IN CONTROL OF YOUR PICTURE HERE.
YOU'RE MODELING FROM THE TOP
TO THE BOTTOM.
DO YOU SEE
HOW YOU'RE VERY STRONG,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, SOFT?
YES.
ALL RIGHTY,
UP NEXT IS SARA.
SARA, I THINK YOU'RE
JUST USED TO THE ALTITUDE.
YOU MANAGED THAT PERFECTLY WELL.
- BAM.
- HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
SARA IS GRETEL
FROM "HANSEL AND GRETEL."
THE LONG SHOT IS GOOD,
YOU GOT GOOD BODY LANGUAGE.
AND IN THE CLOSEUP,
YOU JUST LOOK STARTLED.
YOUR HAND LOOKS WEIRD.
IT JUST KINDA SEEMS STIFF.
UP NEXT IS NNENNA.
YOUR FACE LACKED
A BIT OF CONTROL.
IT JUST WAS SORT OF,
LIKE, NOT THERE.
HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
NNENNA WAS THE PRINCESS FROM
"THE PRINCESS AND THE FROG."
OH, THAT--THAT'S WONDERFUL.
YOU LOOK LIKE YOU'RE FLOATING
THROUGH THE AIR.
THE WIDE SHOT--BEAUTIFUL.
CLOSE UP--
IT'S JUST MEDIOCRE TO ME.
ALL RIGHTY,
UP NEXT IS LESLIE.
I THOUGHT YOU WERE
LIKE A BUFFALO IN BALLET SHOES.
(laughs)
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
LESLIE WAS THE BIG BAD WOLF.
I LIKE THE EVIL LOOK
ON YOUR FACE,
LIKE, "I'M COMIN' TO GET YA."
I'VE NEVER SEEN A HOTTER WOLF
IN MY LIFE.
UP NEXT IS DANIELLE.
I'M COMING.
DANIELLE,
I THOUGHT IT WAS AMAZING
WHEN YOU FELL
AND YOU GOT UP AND SMILED,
THAT WAS A GREAT RECOVERY.
LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
- WOW.
- SHE WAS SNOW WHITE.
OH, DANIELLE,
I GOTTA SAY FALLING
IS DEFINITELY YOUR EXPERTISE.
(laughs)
MM-HMM.
YOU KNOW HOW
TO WORK YOUR FACE.
TO FALL AND STILL KEEP
YOUR NECK AND SHOULDERS
IN THAT CONTROL--
BEAUTIFUL, BEAUTIFUL PICTURE.
- THANK YOU.
- UP NEXT IS BROOKE.
YOU ARE, LIKE,
CLOSET DRAG QUEEN.
ALL RIGHT, BROOKE,
HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
BROOKE WAS THE EMPEROR FROM
"THE EMPEROR'S NEW CLOTHES."
IT LOOKS A LITTLE SHOW GIRL
FOR ME,
AND THE HAND IS DREADFUL.
YOU'VE GOT A LARGE JAW,
AND IT WOULD HAVE BEEN BETTER
IF IT WAS TILTED DOWN.
UP NEXT IS GINA.
I THOUGHT YOU HAD
EXCELLENT BALANCE,
BUT YOU DIDN'T HAVE
ANY PASSION IN YOUR FACE.
I HAD ENDLESS PROBLEMS
WITH GINA.
I PHYSICALLY PUSHED
GINA ONTO THE RUNWAY.
SHE WAS SCREAMING IN HYSTERICS.
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
GINA WAS SLEEPING BEAUTY.
SHE WIDE AWAKE.
THERE'S STILL A WAY
TO BE SLEEPY
AND NOT CLOSE YOUR EYES.
SHE COULD HAVE DONE LIKE THIS.
YOU SHOULD HAVE BEEN DREAMY.
NOT... AH HA HA HA HA!
UP NEXT IS KARI.
BEFORE YOU EVEN WALKED
IN THOSE SHOES,
I SAID, "SHE'S GONNA BE THE ONE
THAT'S GONNA STUMBLE AND FALL."
ALL RIGHT, KARI.
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO--
I'M SORRY.
WHAT'S WRONG, KARI?
I JUST WANTED TO DO WELL,
AND I--IT WAS A MESS,
AND I KNOW IT WAS A MESS.
OKAY, WELL, HOPEFULLY,
YOUR PICTURE'S GOOD.
YOU WERE GOLDILOCKS.
- KARI'S GOT THIS-- APPLE PIE.
- APPLE PIE.
I THINK JUST WORK OUT
AND GET YOURSELF TONED UP
A LITTLE BIT.
NOTHING DRASTIC,
JUST TONE IT UP,
AND I THINK
IT WILL REALLY HELP YOU.
IT WOULD SHOW THE BONES
IN YOUR FACE BETTER, TOO.
UP NEXT IS FURONDA.
YOU MADE ME SO NERVOUS.
I THOUGHT IT WAS RICKETY.
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
THE BLACK RAPUNZEL.
FURONDA, YOU'RE SO SLIM.
WHEN YOU'RE--ALMOST, IF YOU'D
BROKEN YOUR LEGS UP MORE,
I MEAN, A LITTLE BIT WIDER,
PERHAPS IT WOULD HAVE WORKED AS
A WIDE SHOT A LITTLE BIT MORE.
ALL RIGHTY,
UP NEXT IS JOANIE.
YOU SURPRISED ME
WITH THAT LAST LOOK
BEFORE YOU EXITED.
WELL DONE.
HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
AND JOANIE WAS CINDERELLA.
LOOK AT THAT LEG, JOANIE. WOW.
I THINK IT'S FABULOUS.
I LOVE THE EXTENSION OF THE LEG.
"EXQUIRSITE."
WHAT IS IT?
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST,
MISS MOLLIE SUE.
I LOVED
THE SPEEDY TIPPY EXIT.
SPEEDY TIPPY?
SHE STARTED TIPPIN'.
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
MOLLIE WAS LITTLE BOY BLUE.
I GUESS WHAT I'M LOOKING FOR
IS THE TWINKLE IN YOUR EYE.
YOU NEED TO BE YOU,
NOT JUST YOUR BEAUTIFUL SHELL.
I SEE ALL OF YOUR TENSION
IN YOUR NOSE LIKE THIS.
♪♪♪
ALL RIGHTY, SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE,
AND WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I'LL ANNOUNCE WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
- FIRST UP, MOLLIE SUE.
- MOLLIE SUE FALLS FLAT.
NO PERSONALITY COMES OUT OF HER.
I LOVE THIS PHOTO,
SHE'S QUIRKY.
I LIKE THE ANDROGYNY.
JADE.
JADE IS THE WOLF
IN LITTLE RED RIDING HOOD'S
CLOTHING.
THIS IS MY FAVORITE
PICTURE THIS WEEK.
- DANIELLE.
- I THINK DANIELLE IS A STAR.
DANIELLE LOOKS FABULOUS.
SHE WAS ONE OF MY FAVORITES
WHEN I DID THE RUNWAY TEACH.
SHE RECOVERED VERY, VERY WELL.
YOU KNOW, WHEN I SEE HER
LAUGHING, AND THEN SHE WALKED
AND WE SEE THE PAIN HAPPEN,
WHICH MEANS THAT SHE IS
PERFORMING,
WHICH IS WHAT
A MODEL'S SUPPOSED TO DO.
- BROOKE.
- THE THING ABOUT BROOKE IS
SHE HAS A SPECIAL FACTOR.
SHE HAS THAT "IT'S ALL WRONG
BUT IT'S RIGHT" THING.
SHE NEEDS TO LEARN HER ANGLES.
NNENNA.
I THINK SHE HAS GOT
THE MAKINGS OF A TOP MODEL,
BUT I NEED TO SEE
HER PERSONALITY.
FURONDA.
THIS PHOTOGRAPH OF FURONDA--
SHE LOOKS LIKE A SQUASHED
INSECT ONTO A PETRI DISH.
A PASTRY DISH?
- PETRI.
- NOT A PASTRY DISH.
KARI.
SHE'S A LITTLE MORE CATALOGY.
I DON'T THINK THAT THIS IS
A RUNWAY GIRL.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT,
SHE'S VERY EASY TO MOLD,
AND YOU CAN SEE
HOW MAKEUP ARTISTS
AND PHOTOGRAPHERS
AND CLIENTS
WOULD LIKE SOMEONE LIKE KARI.
LESLIE.
SHE DEFINITELY NEEDS
A LITTLE MORE WALKING PRACTICE.
THIS PICTURE OF LESLIE--
IT'S SEXY,
BUT SHE'S STILL GOTTA MAKE IT
A LITTLE BIT MORE MODEL-Y.
- SARA.
- IT'S NOT A GREAT SHOT OF SARA.
SARA IS A BEAUTIFUL GIRL,
SHE IS, BUT I AM STARTING
TO FEEL A LITTLE AWKWARDNESS.
I KNEW I WAS SKINNY,
AND I KNEW I WAS WEIRD,
AND I USED THAT.
GINA.
CONSIDERING
THE CIRCUMSTANCES,
I THINK IT'S A NICE PICTURE,
AND THAT'S JUST ABOUT IT.
THIS IS A MESS.
HER FACE IS PRETTY,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
SHE'S SORT OF UNCOMFORTABLE
WITH IT.
JOANIE.
WELL, I ACTUALLY THOUGHT
HER WALK WAS THE BEST TODAY.
- SHE TURNED IT ON.
- THIS IS A GREAT PICTURE.
AS A MODEL,
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO TAKE
DIFFERENT HAIR STYLES.
SHE CAN'T TAKE THAT.
WELL, WE'VE DECIDED
WHO'S GOING HOME.
♪♪♪
11 GIRLS STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE TEN PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS.
AND THESE PHOTOS
REPRESENT THE TEN OF YOU
THAT WILL STILL BE
IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
JADE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
DANIELLE.
EASE ON DOWN THE ROAD.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THIS PICTURE
IS ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL.
THANK YOU.
BROOKE.
JOANIE.
MOLLIE.
THE JUDGES AREN'T GETTING
A SENSE OF WHO YOU ARE.
WHO'S MOLLIE SUE?
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
SARA.
FURONDA.
THE BIG BAD WOLF--LESLIE.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
NNENNA.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
WILL GINA AND KARI
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
WHICH MEANS I WILL
ONLY CALL THIS NAME.
THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO YOUR HOUSE,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS,
AND GO HOME.
I'M GONNA START WITH YOU, KARI.
YOU HAD TWO
BEAUTIFUL PICTURES.
FIRST ONE--STRONG.
SECOND ONE--STRONG.
THIRD ONE--
(imitates screeching sound)
AND THE SAD THING IS,
A GIRL LIKE YOU
THAT IS NOT NECESSARILY
SUPER TALL
OR HAS A MODEL PROPORTION
HAS TO BE ALMOST PERFECT.
AND THEN, YOU NEARLY
FELL OFF THIS RUNWAY.
GINA.
WHY ARE YOU SMILING SO MUCH?
I'M TRYING TO STAY
A LITTLE BIT POSITIVE.
IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE
THE JUDGES ARE LIKE,
"WHO THE HELL IS THAT GIRL?
SHE'S QUIET.
SHE SEEMS CONFUSED."
AND THEN THIS PHOTO TODAY
JUST MAKES THEM SAY,
"WHY IS SHE HERE?"
AND SOMETIMES,
WHEN THE JUDGES DON'T THINK
YOUR LOOK IS STRONG ENOUGH,
MAYBE YOUR RUNWAY WALK
COULD POSSIBLY HELP THAT.
BUT NEITHER OF YOU WERE GOOD
IN EITHER OF THOSE AREAS.
♪♪♪
GINA.
A TOP MODEL
IS JUST NOT ABOUT BEIN' PRETTY
AND HAVIN'
BEAUTIFUL CHEEK BONES.
IT'S ABOUT WALKING INTO A ROOM,
WOWING THE CROWD,
SHOWING THEM WHO YOU ARE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU, KARI.
♪♪♪
IN MY MIND, I THOUGHT
I WAS GONNA GET A PICTURE.
I REALLY DID.
GINA'S SHOCKED,
AND I THINK SHE EXPECTED
TO GO HOME.
SHE NEEDS TO STICK UP
FOR HERSELF
'CAUSE NO ONE ELSE WILL
AND NEEDS TO, YOU KNOW,
BE CONFIDENT IN HERSELF.
AND DON'T LET JADE
WALK ALL OVER YOU.
IT'S DEFINITELY HARD
TO LEAVE THESE GIRLS,
BUT THIS ALSO MEANS
I GET TO GO HOME.
♪♪♪
Tyra: COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
JANICE GIVES
SOME TOUGH LESSONS.
WELCOME TO JANICE DICKINSON'S
POSING CLASS.
BOTH IN...
I DON'T WANNA HEAR THE NEXT
THING OUTTA YOUR MOUTH,
BUT GO AHEAD.
AND OUT OF THE CLASSROOM.
ZIP IT, BITCH,
YOU'RE DEAD IN MY BOOK.
AND GINA FINDS THE STRENGTH
TO STAND UP TO JADE.
YOU SAY YOU FEEL SORRY FOR ME?
I FEEL VERY SORRY FOR YOU,
YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND ANYTHING.